so I came to Nottingham in 1980 to do a
physics degree and worked through that
but towards the end of it I got very
interested in computing and fact I ended
up doing physics with computing that's
where I met Dave and the other people
who were setting up the early computer
science group and then he said after I'd
finished that I've got a bit of spare
money would you like to work on some
typesetting stuff there's all sorts of
interesting things happening so I did I
worked on that for a year I think we're
Dave doing various things including this
connection for the exams machine and all
that interesting stuff never mind said
Julian quite wryly so we'll keep the
lower level and then I got really
interested in networking us as that was
just starting to come about and I worked
with another lecturer called Hugh Smith
and he had contacts with UCL and so we
got into this sort of Internet and
ARPANET and early connections to that
and I started working on email software
to try and make sense of all this stuff
that was going on get rid of all these
exclamation marks in your groups and
things like that and just try and make
it simpler it was quite early on so it
was about 1984 or three I think I got
involved in it at that time the the
internet was well it was all just
ARPANET so it was the American
connection and we had a very very
tenuous connection we had some friends
at University College London and they
had a satellite link to the ARPANET
they'd had for a while and we were in
the mass building which is what oh they
are today and we didn't actually have a
connection to the outside world but
psychology did say you could connect
across to psychologists computer and
dial up London log into a lot of
London's nodes and then you could use
the internet very very slow and of
course it was going across satellite so
you connect to I don't know we weren't
very many sites but there were a few
places you can pick up software so you
log into those
but because it was going over a
satellite you typed like in that letter
a and it would take about three seconds
for the a to come back and so you'd
start typing and then you get very
confused halfway through and have to
delete it all and little painfully slow
but we thought it was wonderful at the
time so it was about you know 20 minutes
or something to get onto the end of that
from here but but we did manage it
alongside that at the same time there's
sort of a more anarchic network called
Usenet which was just that was machines
that you were friendly whether you talk
to other machines and and a whole
grouping came out of that so we also
have that see you could use that
alongside e so you send email to
somebody and say do you know a good site
I can go to to pick up software for this
battle the other and they'd send
something back over that but it was all
very very disconnected so I remember we
connected to a Lancaster and then
Lancaster connected to Kent and Kent
connected to Amsterdam and Amsterdam was
the European gateway they could then
connect ganden very early stage you
actually have to work out your route so
if you wanted to email somebody you'd
say right so go from Nottingham to
Lancaster to Kent to Amsterdam to seismo
to Rutgers to something other and you
could eventually work out where to go
and how it would get there
ah so much fun we had email in the
department for a long time and then as
psychology and other places got
connected we canwe centered around
campus
I can't think who I would send the first
one to probably somebody a University
College London because we did a lot of
work with them early on and actually
have some connection which is how we got
connected to the Internet
I do remember desperately trying to get
in contact with Brian Kernighan and
sending email after email along these
different paths over Amsterdam and sighs
motor it was called research research
everybody's name was just their computer
name so research was the AT&T computer
node so and eventually I remember it was
late on a Friday night I was watching
the logs and suddenly saw an email come
in it was from Brian rush down to Davie
brows but as well we've got a connection
look here's the route that you need to
use and he scribbled it down and they
don't we had contact there very soon
after that we started sort of
collaborating so I was working with
somebody in the California and we were
working on software that got switched
around so I'd be working on it during UK
time and then he'd be working on at
Californian time and then he'd send me
changes and yeah I was mostly done over
email we didn't need very much because
in the UK we were still we weren't using
tcp/ip we were told we had to use x.25
at the time but we cheated and we ran
some tcp over x.25 and we ran strange
protocols that allowed us to connect the
Internet and we did actually even
managed to have a sort of talk system
where you could type a message and it
would appear in California and vice
versa that was a great day when that
first happened I guess that was about
nineteen eighty six or seven when that
we managed to cobble together enough
protocol to get that all
and you mention email the instant thing
you think of these days it's probably
webmail or a client email with
attachments just being dealt with you
couldn't do attachments at all though
you could sometimes because it was all
just text so sometimes you could wrap
them up in interesting ways and there
was particularly one self-extracting
it was called a char archive
self-extracting it was actually a small
shell script program for UNIX and so
your message arrived and you just ran
the contents the message as a program
and it extracted itself and you could
send files that way but that was fairly
late on because we had very little
bandwidth at the time so it was more
very quick short emails and this is a
place to pick up a file from we would
try and get the file somewhere near
nearer to the person so that they could
pick it up with a reasonable speed so
this is a message saved from 1987 and
this is the path you can see here so it
starts off over here this is the person
and then this is all the places it's
been through sighs Moe was a popular
place in I think it's in Virginia or
somewhere like that but it have great
connectivity lots of other places and
then down here we have MC VAX which is
the European node and then it trickles
across the UK to get to get to us from
here so you know I was kind of one of
the early messages and you have to
remember these paths and write them down
so that you you could get back to them
and this is kind of the route it took it
jumped around in Europe a little and
then left over across the Atlantic and
then rattled around there until it ended
up where it went to and this is just
earth this is the SAP net that was so
this bit here is all of the US and
there's a connection here coming over
the satellite to go and hillie down in
Cornwall and a landline up to UCL I
remember when they finally got to
upgrading that they went to a
transatlantic cable or something
tap a tort at 6:00 transatlantic
telephone cable 6:00 when that was laid
down suddenly we had more bandwidth than
we ever knew what to do with until about
two months later when we fully utilized
it all that's the way it goes that was
what a lot of the internet was for and
that's still what the ugly intents for
she's having very little purpose but you
know back then they took it to a to a
different level and we'd have to go to
this really dark room and the computers
were green little I had an amiga
computer right this is like an Amiga 500